hipsters get ready you're about to
crucify man on YouTube thrive so if you
remember I was looking forward to drive
drive stars Ryan Gosling and he plays a
driver stunt driver by day and then he's
like you know a guy from Grand Theft
Auto he drives criminals around by night
and he has his set rules man he's like
we meet here you're on time you got five
minutes I Drive I don't carry a gun you
do the dirty work I will drive you
anywhere but in that five minutes I'm
yours when he was listening off the
rules at the very beginning of the movie
I was like dude this is awesome I love
people like this a little bit when
they're like that methodical and you got
to be on time cuz you know he's gonna
leave your ass behind if you're not and
on that the beginning of this movie is
so awesome he's driving these guys on a
job and he's just working his craft he
is a badass behind the whale and then
after that the beginning credits come on
and I was like dude I am so hype for
this right now there's no real human
being who can watch the first five
minutes of this movie and be like ah not
my thing but then after that you know
the movie continues and the movie really
slows down it slows down to a pretty
drastic degree in about a half an hour
end of the movie after you know about
ten lines of dialogue have been spoken I
was like this is truly an arthouse movie
and you guys know arthouse movies
they're just not my thing and people
were saying that drive is like the
perfect blend of art house meets action
not really it's just art house I mean in
terms of action both the action
sequences are in the trailer there are
two driving sequences two was at the
very beginning of the movie and the next
one's like halfway into the movie in
between it focuses on Ryan Gosling
meeting this girl you know and she all
makes him feel warm and fuzzy although
he's not really the warm and fuzzy type
he just kind of sits there and stares
and gives a look and doesn't say much
does it just be like oh you're a stunt
driver for a movie that's awesome
anything I've heard of okeydoke it's
kind of like that which I get is his
character because you know he could kill
you and I like knowing that I like
knowing this whole time that guy could
just snap and kill people and Ryan
Gosling plays it perfectly he's a good
actor the guy plays a really stoic
driver who barely talks and could
probably snap your neck with his pinky
perfectly there were some scenes where
you're like dude that guy is just gonna
murder some folks you know you didn't
want to be on the receiving end of it
but you knew you wanted to see what he
was gonna do now when people defend this
movie I cannot argue their points I
can't say that they're totally wrong
because they say the movies well filmed
and it is well filmed and well acted
it's well acted everyone's a good actor
in this movie there's like no weak link
but
doesn't change the fact that I found the
movie to be really boring at least for
half of it you know the exciting it
shows in the trailer that's the halfway
mark on if you like arthouse movies
you're going to love drive and you're
going to defend it to your dying breath
watch it now before it's shown to you in
every film class you have later on in
life if you don't like arthouse movies I
don't think you're going to like drive
so for me the movie was a two ative
Falls
alright guys your favorite driving movie
that has to do with drivers or driving
that has more than two driving scenes
what's your favorite comment below let
me know in any case if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more